I want to go over the most common forms
of meditation how each of them work what
benefits each bring and also who each of
them are for the next formal meditation
on our list is Mantra meditation how
does it work Mantra meditation is a
special form of meditation where you
focus on repeating a phrase or a series
of words over and over again the best
mantras are positively phrased for
example I am calm is a better Mantra to
repeat than I do not worry what are the
benefits to this the benefits really
depend on which Mantra you choose when
you repeat a phrase to yourself so many
times and focus on it with such
intensity you start to believe it in a
way Mantra meditation can reprogram the
way you think and view yourself who is
this for mantra meditation is for anyone
who feels like they have a certain
belief about themselves or about life
that is holding them back because it
allows you to pinpoint a specific
problem that you have and fix it follow
us for more helpful tips